Peter Thiel co-founded PayPal he was one
of the very first investors in Facebook
if anyone knows a lot about big tech and
its power and his potential dangers its
Peter Thiel so it means something when
he warns that Google the world's most
powerful company has become a threat to
American national security they may even
have committed treason he says well
speak at the national conservatism
conference in Washington yesterday deal
warned that Google may have been
infiltrated by Chinese intelligence and
ought to be subject to immediate
investigation by the FBI and the CIA
we're happy to Peter Thiel join us Peter
thanks a lot for coming on sober thanks
I mean what did you mean when you said
that well it it was just in the form of
a set of questions I asked where you
know artificial intelligence is
something people talk about non-stop in
Silicon Valley but they almost never
talk about its dual use if it's real if
this is a real thing it obviously can
also be used by the military it'll be
weaponized in all sorts of ways and it's
an important national security question
as to who has it there's this very
peculiar background where Google is
working with with the Chinese communist
government and not with the US military
so the project maven decision was a
decision not to work with AI with with
the US military but they're working with
the Communist Chinese and so the
question is you know from the outside is
just what in the world is going on there
and I I sort of suggested a few
different possibilities but I think it's
been just they described it as a
Manhattan Project for AI and so if you
go around broadcasting that you're
building the Manhattan Project for AI I
would think this naturally would it draw
the attention of foreign intelligence
agencies you know I think the Chinese
are competent enough the Ministry of
State Security is likely to infiltrate
at Google and and then I think the
Google management has sort of decision
of either letting the software go out
the front door or figuring it it'll get
stolen anyway and go off the backdoor
when you say you believe that Chinese
state security is likely to have
infiltrated Google what would that look
if you call if you if you say you're
building a Manhattan Project force for
AI don't you think that would attract
the interest of foreign intelligence
agents just hidden in plain sight
and and then it's and then you know and
then they are on well I think there are
sort of all these all these ways that
that you know Chinese nationals are
engaged in espionage in the u.s. it's
you know I'm not even it's
understandable that China is doing that
they see themselves in a very serious
competition with the US but but we're
not particularly on our guard about it
and and if you have sort of a series of
super futuristic tech projects that you
broadcast the whole world it's at least
a suspicion and then and then the weird
the weird fact that's indisputable is
that Google is working with Communist
China but not with the US military on
its breakthrough a objects well that's
the that's the question I think I think
one explanation is they figure they have
to because it'll gets if they don't give
it to them through the front door it'll
get stolen through the back door so
first answers they have to and then I
think of course there's probably you
know a broad base of Google employees
that are you know ideologically super
left-wing sort of woke and think that
China is better than the US or that the
US is worse than China it's always it's
always the more it's more anti-american
and everything but this is by definition
a threat to American national security
as you point out so if sundar Pichai was
sitting right here what would you say
now well I would say answer my three
questions
how many foreign intelligence agencies
have infiltrated Google has the Chinese
have the Chinese in particular
infiltrated and and why are you why are
you working with Communist China and not
the US what is the reason you're doing
you think the questions you raised and
this this is not in any way to minimize
their importance are kind of obvious
questions why hasn't the US government
ascertain the answers why it's possible
that there are people in the US
government looking into it and haven't
told us but but yeah I think I think the
FBI and CIA would be the natural place
is to look into it the FBI would look at
it from the domestic side the CIA would
look at it from the outside and and
would try to look at seeing from the
outside their people you know
controlling people inside Google or so
it's this is almost rhetoric but if
someone just built a lot of companies as
you have do you think it would have been
possible to create to incubate and grow
a company like Google in China or I
don't think
I think the u.s. is still better at
innovation and at starting things but it
certainly can be copied and replicated
right and and something like this is
true of all the breakthrough
technologies we have most of them are
still originating and developing and in
the West but they don't give us much of
an advantage if they get transferred you
know in a matter of a few years if not a
few not a matter of months I have to ask
you
I assume you're watching the Democratic
primaries unfold who's the most
impressive candidate in that race do you
think well I'm most scared by Elizabeth
Warren you know I think I think she's
the the one who's actually talking about
the economy which is the only thing that
I think the thing that I think matters
by far the most yeah and then I think
almost all the others are equally
unimpressive in the sense that it's all
identity politics of one one flavor or
another and I wouldn't want to rank how
unimpressive they are since that would
be forcing me to rank the different
identity and which one's more privileged
and more special and that would be a
dangerous thing to get into it's hard to
know it's I just don't think Elizabeth
Warren's the dangerous one that's right
Peter Jill's great to see you thank you
Thanks